c'est donc un jour de l'indépendance sur
fond de fusillades et de fortes tensions
j'en discute avec charles philippe david
présidente de l'observatoire sur les
états-unis à l'uqam bonsoir bonsoir
d'abord j'ai envie de vous demander les
américains semblent à tel point divisé
qu'on peut se demander qu'est-ce qu'ils
célèbrent aujourd'hui c'est une bonne
question je dirais déjà que les
événements d'aujourd'hui le rêve
américain se transforme presque un
cauchemar américain en réponse à votre
question je dirai est ce qu on célèbre
les etats-unis aujourd'hui où on célèbre
les étapes des junies ils n'ont jamais
été aussi divisés et polarisé presque en
tout cas de leur histoire que
qu'aujourd'hui on est c'est vraiment
très difficile pour eux de surmonter ses
divisions alors évidemment on peut se
dire que normalement une fête comme
celle là devrait rassembler mais avec
les événements d'aujourd'hui vous voyez
à quel point juste les armes à feu en
corse est un problème qui est loin
d'être résolue vous avez vraiment deux
camps politiques qui s'affrontent et il
n'y a plus de centre il n'ya plus d'elle
modéré si on est républicaine on a eu
les démocrates et vice versa d'ailleurs
je vous dirai dans le jeu et la vie
politique américaine aujourd'hui rares
sont les républicains plutôt démocrate
et vice versa encore une fois rançon les
démocrates qui serait république est
donc vraiment le centre politique
américain est fragilisée etc et c'est
dommage dans un sens parce que la
majorité pas écrasante mais quand même
une majorité des américains pourraient à
la rigueur s'entendent sur le fait par
exemple on doit permettre l'avortement
on devrait contrôler les armes à feu et
on devrait avoir un processus électoral
plus efficace mais une fois qu'on a dit
ça après sabin les partisans les activer
les gros plaisait les politiciens
contribuer alimentent cette polarisation
qui dure depuis trop longtemps si bien
qu on revient toujours à cette idée
qu'il y a toujours deux cas on dirait
bien qu'ils s'affrontent et il n'y a pas
de salle despas de modérer ya pas de
voix
donc qu'ils se font entendre au centre
de l'échiquier vous dirais que c'est la
faillite de quoi au juste
je dirais que cette faillite du discours
civique de cette entente qui existait
déjà parfois entre les parties de
césaire qu'on appelait une aire
bipartisane qui a prévalu bon il ya
longtemps je dirais a été vraiment mise
en herbe ont depuis un moment mais
surtout mise à mal par d'une équipe je
vais prononcer ce soir le fameux nom
n'est ce pas dans nos craintes dans
l'autre entre les années de la
présidence dans l'autre pour décupler
est fragilisée à un point presque
irréversible cette démocratie américaine
le dommage est considérable dans
beaucoup de domaines à l'international
d'ailleurs comme dans la vie politique
américaine et la société américaine tom
crone dans l'époque le responsable est
un peu comme un pyromane il a profité du
fait qu'il y avait déjà plein
d'allumettes et un brazy pour
l'enflammer et de manière spectaculaire
parce que c'est vrai que cette hyper
polarisation elle a pris naissance déjà
au moins il ya une trentaine d'années au
milieu des années 1990 et puis de
président sans présidence les choses ce
sont je dirais gâtés et dans l'autre on
s'est réunis dans un méga cocktails
molotov toutes les causes et les racines
de cette polarisation pour les décuplé
comme jeudi rendent presque irréversible
ce jeu politique extrêmement funeste est
toxique pour l'avenir de la démocratie
américaine tente et sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui jeanne philippe david on
a line dans une même phrase des mots qui
aurait semblé complètement farfelu
autrefois guerre civile aux états-unis
en parlant au présent ou froid sur
proches c'est grave quand même oui et
c'est depuis honnêtement l'émeute et
puis les événements du 7 janvier 2021
que toute cette thèse a pris de
l'ampleur et prendre l'importance alors
bien avant de déclarer qu'il y aura
certainement une guerre civile aussi
tenu faire attention je vous dirais
qu'on est la croisée des chemins ou bien
ils vont trouver une façon de surmonter
leurs différends ou bien ces différents
vont s'accroître et ça va dépendre des
choix que font les institutions et les
politiciens dans leur conduite dans
leurs discours dans leurs agissements
politiques et c'est vrai que lors des
gens par exemple avec le jugement rovi
oued on a un exemple d'institutions qui
contribuent je crois à cette hyper
polarisation et a aggravé la situation
et ce n'est que le début imaginez qu'un
dans l'épreuve a annoncé parce que j'ai
presque pas de doute qui va le faire qui
va se présenter pour les élections de
2024 salaires loin leur ça s'en vient
tranquillement le jour où il le fait là
vous avez encore des jeunes tout une
psychose politique qui va se déclencher
parce que ça va ça va évidemment à
définir les termes du jeu politique
qu'entre maintenant et l'élection de
2024 on a beaucoup parlé de rovi wade
écoutez il ya une autre décision qui
s'en vient mourir sur un peu que la cour
suprême doit dont elle doit annoncer sa
décision à l'automne sur la processus
électoral même est ce que les états au
les pleins pouvoirs pour gérer le
processus électoral en vue de la
prochaine élection présidentielle et
définir les termes du jeu à leur façon
où il y aura encore l'espoir d'une loi
fédérale qui existent pour en chasser la
tenue du vote et la tenue du processus
électoral si la cour suprême se rangeait
comm réd du côté de la version
originelle que les états ont pleins
pouvoirs de la constitution et affaiblir
donc un ici l'état fédéral on va avoir
de gros gros gros problème pour deux en
prévision de 2024 je vous assure ça
risque d'être vraiment pas une sinécure
cette histoire est ce que vous voyez une
façon de de remédier à tout ça est ce
qu'il y ait un espoir on voit déjà dans
les sondages 85% de la population dit
que le pays ne s'en va pas dans la bonne
direction
est ce que vous êtes optimiste
ben je suis pop et j'aimerais trouver
des lueurs d'espoir et je vais vous dire
à l'occasion de cette guerre
épouvantable à piment barbares qui se
déroule en ukraine j'aurais pensé que le
ralliement autour de joe biden pour une
réponse qui leader fort et musclé des
états unis dans les limites évidemment
de pour provoquer poutine une troisième
guerre mondiale et d'aider l'ukraine
on est peut-être changer un peu les
idées des américains pour rallier leur
président ce qui est arrivé dans le
passé lorsqu'on a une guerre oui bah ce
n'est pas vraiment le cas c'est à dire
c'est le corps pour la guerre en ukraine
oui c'est vrai ya pas beaucoup de voix
discordantes les américains sont assez
d'accord avec joe biden là dessus mais
ça ne se traduit pas par une popularité
plus grand du président des états unis
et ça il n'y a pas d'effet de ralliement
sur d'autres sujets comme tout ce qu'on
évoque armes à feu parce que c'est
lectorale avortement est institué donc
malheureusement je pense que des gens
vont surveiller les élections de
mi-mandat qui s'en vient au mois de
novembre et j'ai l'impression que
l'économie va être le facteur dominant
bien sûr l'avortement aussi mais
l'économie en premier et ça évidemment
ça favorise des républicains parce qu'on
reproche à joba donne toute la situation
misérable sur le plan économique dans
laquelle les états unis se retrouvent
alors lui maire de l'électorat je pense
pas va s'améliorer et donc ses divisions
cette polémique où cette polarisation
auxquels on fait référence vous et moi
moi je pense qu'elle va malheureusement
s'accentuer ça va prendre un miroir pour
les américains je n'ai pas retrouvé un
petit peu le sens le bon sens des
affaires publiques en terminant est ce
que vous pensez qu'il y aura des
accusations portées contre donald
rheault alors ça c'est encore ça c'est
un autre sujet qui pourrait enflammer
tout le monde est ce que le ministre de
la justice marc gales en prenant acte de
toutes les dépositions et de tous les
documents qui sont transmis par la
commission du 6 janvier après les
témoignages et les comparutions qui
seront terminés bientôt va décider de
porter des accusations criminelles
contre l'ancien président des états unis
je voudrais dire que ce serait la
première fois qu'un président des états
unis serait ainsi traduits en justice
ça veut pas dire évidemment qu'il serait
déclaré un nécessairement coupable au
plus haut niveau passe ou paris que ça
pour aller jusqu'en cour suprême
l'aquos prêtre décidé que la
jurisprudence ne permet pas de croire
qu'on puisse accuser un président des
états unis mais imaginez une seconde le
président des états unis une anciens
dans l'autre up accusés et peut-être
même condamné les faits sur l'électorat
jeu l'ignorent beaucoup de gens vont
applaudir mais un certain nombre de gens
qui vont être bien fâché parmi eux
damman tous les trompettes de
l'électorat républicain qu'il appuie
donc à surveiller à suivre ce n'est pas
fini la rentrée votre spectaculaire
merci beaucoup s'est affaissé en prix